[Music]
foreign
did you know that there are 30
Transformers that are either mechanimals
have their own Beast modes dinosaur and
master modes and all of them are in live
action movies not cartoons no idea okay
let's showcase them according to science
and let's get into it firstly the
microcons these microcons are swarms of
little robots shaped like ball bearings
which unfold to reveal the robot hidden
inside that unravel in the shape of a
bug or a Mite around one centimeters in
size
number two the incepticons measuring
less than 10 centimeters long or a
couple of inches insecticons are the
Decepticons micro drones in the form of
small insects capable of surveillance in
urban and tight situations
number three Cisco aeronet The Cisco bot
was brought to life when Sam with Wiki
dropped a piece of a shot of the old
spot he has a bit of light robot mode
and is around 10 centimeters or 4 inches
number four scalpel's assistant
scalpel's assistants are wiry creepy
little robots that help scalpel the
doctor the one that ended Sam's mouth
was in the shape of a multi-identical
worm it is around 20 centimeters or 8
inches long
number five scalpel although in his
alternative mode he appears as a
microscope this tiny Decepticon doctor
actually has the shape of a weird insect
and it is around 30 centimeters or one
feet tall in size
number six mini slug one of the three
small danbots seen in the last Knight
movie mini slug resembles the mighty
slug as he appears as a baby Triceratops
of only around 30 centimeters in height
number 7 mini strafe this is another one
of the tiny Dinobots and flies around
the junkyard in The Last Knight
ministrative also looks like a tiny
pterodactyl but has only one head unlike
the mighty strafe number eight mini
Grimlock this baby T-Rex dynabot is
grimlock's Junior and is named as such
mini Grimlock is bigger than the other
dynabots by only a small margin stunning
40 centimeters tall or 1.3 feet
number nine steel jaw steel Jaws are
wolf-like creatures used by lockdown to
hunt down Intruders and pray that
Venture into his ship in Age of
Extinction these canine robots are 1.5
meters or 5 feet tall but are still very
powerful
number 10 laser beak this Transformer
serves the Decepticons primarily as a
scout and a spy for sound wave laser
beak comes in the shape of a bird but
with a very long neck and also has a
wingspan of 2 meters or 6.5 feet wide
number 11 ravage just like laser beak
ravage is a partner of sound wave and is
a sentient mechanimal from Cybertron
having the design of a panther or a lion
ravage is 2.2 meters tall or a little
over 7 feet
number 12 scorpino this Decepticon was a
minion of the larger blackout and was
the first transformer robot to be seen
in live action in the first movie
scorpion up as his name suggests appears
as a scorpion over eight feet or 2.4
meters tall but has a very long tail
number 13 hatchet as a member of the
dreads a group of Decepticons Hatchet is
unique as he appears as a four-legged
apex predator of some sort Hatchet is
3.6 meters or 12 feet tall the smallest
of the dreads
number 14 cheetor he is the youngest
member of the maximals which are beast
type descendants of the Autobots cheetor
takes the form of a cheetah which is 10
to 12 feet tall or around 3 to 3.6
meters key will be seen in the next
movie The Rise of the bees
number 15 rhinox regarded as the brains
and muscle of the maximals rhinox as his
name suggests takes the form of a rhino
and desires only to smash he is
estimated to be 6 meters or 20 feet tall
number 16 glug one of the five and
phonicons that together can combine to
form in furniture by themselves they are
demon-like Transformers so they have
monster modes and they are 21 feet or
6.4 meters tall Glock is also a deadly
Beast just by himself
number 17 Gorge these and fun cons
although in toys and cartoons have
distinct designs in The Last Knight
movie however they are designed to look
very similar to each other Gorge is
another one of the same size
number 18 rupture this infanticon can
actually transform in his base mode into
a flying creature kind of like a bat but
in the last night his feature wasn't
really seen he is also 6.4 meters or 21
feet tall
number 19 skulk this specimen here is a
deadly melee fighter and with the other
quintessence demon and funny cons will
combine to form the deadly infernicus
skull is also of the same size as the
others
number 20 thrash the last of the five
infanticons on this list in other media
he can transform into a two-headed
dragon-like wolf but here he was seen
the same as the others and as like the
others he stands 21 feet or 6.4 meters
tall in the movie The Last Night
number 21 Optimus primal he is the
leader of the animal type maximals and
takes the form of a gorilla in beast
mode Primal is estimated to be the same
size as Optimus Prime around 25 feet or
7.6 meters tall
number 22 infernicus he was quintess's
enforcer menacing Optimus Prime into
submission in the last night and was
formed by his constituent demonic
Inferno cones he is a beast he is 42
feet tall a 12.8 meters in height
number 23 air razor she is the aerial
segment of the maximals also the heart
and the nurturing one eraser takes the
form of a huge bird of prey a falcon to
be precise she has an estimated wingspan
of around 18 to 21 meters or 60 to 70
feet wide
number 24 slug now we come to the
dynabots again the big ones slug in his
robot mode is 71 feet or 21.6 meters
tall slug is the dynabot that transforms
into a gigantic Triceratops but with a
monstrous spiky armor
number 25 strafe this is the two-headed
pterodactyl Dinobot that was seen in Age
of Extinction strafe is actually smaller
than slug in size in robot mode but in
base mode has a wingspan of 30 to 36
meters or 100 to 120 feet wide
number 26 Grimlock this is the leader of
the data boss and has the form of an
iacon Knight in robot mode but in base
mode he takes the form of a fire
breathing T-Rex he is 84 feet or 25.6
meters tall
27 is gone he is the biggest of the
dynabots but also the most recluse
taking the form of a Spinosaurus he is
of a similar size to Grimlock but is a
bit taller at 87 feet or 26.5 meters in
height
number 28 Devastator although a
construct gone a combined form
devastated in Revenge of the Fallen does
resemble a gorilla slash bear monster
that sucks in rubble through his mouth
he is a hundred feet or 30 meters in
height
number 29 Dragon storm one of the most
powerful Transformers ever a combined
form of the 12 Knights of earcon
dragonstorm takes the form of a gigantic
three-headed metal dragon around 60
meters or 200 feet long
and lastly the driller the largest
Subterranean life form native to
Cybertron enormous multitentical bees
capable of borrowing through the ground
or through buildings with ease these
gigantic Transformers are 300 meters or
1080 feet long
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam